It's great to welcome to the program today,
John Berry, who is author of the book The
Great Influenza The Story of the Deadliest
Pandemic in History, also professor at Tulane
University's School of Public Health and Tropical
Medicine. John, so great to have you on.
Thanks.
So here we've heard of a number of different
assertions made about the flu pandemic of
1918 from the president and from others, sort
of in the context of coronavirus. Let's let's
just figure out a little bit more about that.
What are the origins of that pandemic?
Well, no one knows for certain. It's like
a cub at 19, an animal virus. All influenza
viruses have a natural reservoir and birds,
but they can infect mammals and an animal
virus jump species to humans spread around
the world, infected about a third of the world's
population and killed fifty two hundred million
people. Adjusted for population that would
equal about two hundred and twenty eight,
a foreigner and 40 million people today. So
fortunately, as bad as covered 19 is, it's
it's not nearly as lethal as the 1918 pandemic.
What was the sort of full duration, as we
understand it, of that pandemic?
Well, it really and total covered from the
spring of 1918 until the fall of 1920. However,
two thirds of the deaths, perhaps more than
two thirds of the deaths occurred in a 14
or 15 week period in the fall of 1918. The
first wave was very spotty myth and we're
not really sure exactly. But my guess is it
although it's pretty widespread in Western
Europe and in U.S. Army camps in the spring,
it probably missed most of this country and
most of the world. Then A, I think the virus
that spring away was also very mild, so mild.
There were medical journal articles that said
this looks and smells like influenza, but
it's not killing enough people. So it's probably
not influenza that turned around very rapidly.
The virus mutated and then you started seeing.
Scientists saying this looks and smells like
influenza, but we've never seen an influenza
that killed like this. Although it was, of
course, in that second way, I said 14 to 15
weeks from mid-September through most of December.
Then there was a third wave. In late winter
and early spring of 1919. So it's very unusual
to have two waves of influenza and the same
influenza season. Very unusual. So the virus
had mutated again, I guess. Then in 1920,
it came back and that was pretty much it that
the virus probably mutated further toward
mildness. And in addition, our immune systems,
having seen it several times, began to deal
with it more efficiently. So it gradually
became seasonal influenza.
Do you know why the president often refers
to 1917 when talking about that pandemic?
I have to ask him.
OK. It does not.
There's nothing in your understanding that
has really nothing scientifically or epidemiologically
that would justify going at 19. My guess is
that he said it once and he doesn't like to
admit any error over even the tiniest things.
So rather than correct himself in future,
he just kind of wrapped his arms around it,
as he seems to do with other mistakes.
Fair pay in terms of the name often called
the Spanish flu. Can you talk about, number
one, why it has that name, but also sort of
the early hot spots that we often think about
as the places where it really started to spread?
Most likely explanation is for the name is
that Spain was not at war. Warring countries
censored the press. It didn't like to print
anything that was negative. That might hurt
morale. It might hurt the war effort. Spain
wasn't at war. Plus, the king got sick. Celebrity
culture than it is now. So the Spanish press
wrote about it and other newspapers around
the world wrote about it and picked up the
name Spanish influenza. Except in Spain, where
they called it other things. The first known
eruption was actually in January in rural
Kansas of the southwest corner of the state.
And in early February, we see it in New York
City. You know, it hit the army camps in First
and Camp Funston in Kansas. Fort Riley in
early March spread to about half of the Army
camps in the United States during the spring,
seemed to travel with the U.S. troops to Europe,
although would have gotten there anyway. As
I said, it was in New York and almost certainly
other places, even before the Army camp. So
it would have spread eventually. But the U.S.
troops didn't seem to bring it to Europe in
late March and in April they accelerated the
spread to sites.
And you know it.
So you said earlier widespread in Western
Europe. Lindorff, the German commander, launched
an offensive to try to win the war before
American soldiers arrived in large numbers.
He blamed an outbreak of influenza among his
troops for the failure of battle offensive.
Of course, I think that's looking for an excuse.
There was influence on the other side of the
trenches as well, although the first known
cases were in January in rural Kansas. The
scientific community thinks at the end it
is possible that it actually started there.
But I advanced that hypothesis in my book.
But there's been a lot of work since my book
came out originally in 2004, and I myself
have backed off the Kansas hypothesis. I think
it's more likely it started in China. Other
other hypotheses. Some very good virologists
think it started in France, Vietnam as a possibility.
And you never know. It could have been New
York City. Most virologists think that it
was circulating for at least a year, perhaps
learning how to better infect humans.
And some think it was circulating for a couple
of years. So, again, we'll never know where
it actually did start that spring wave. It
was spotty and mild.
In July, though, first, widespread outbreaks
of the lethal second wave were noted in Switzerland.
In fact, it was it was so bad in Switzerland.
U.S. military intelligence report said that
this is being called influenza, but it's actually
the Black Plague of the Middle Ages. It wasn't
it wasn't swine.
So when it when it comes to the obviously
medicine was very different at that time.
International travel was different at that
time. Media was different at that time. When
it comes to mitigation, what was it that was
done? You know, we talk about the quarantines
and the shut downs are unprecedented. And
in a sense, they are. But there were also
some of these techniques applied back then.
Exactly. Most cities in the United States.
Not quite all of them, but very close to all
of them, close to all sorts of things.
They weren't actually quite as extreme as
what we've done. They closed places, public
gathering schools, etc. Most of them did it
too late to have maximum impact. Just as I
think in the United States, we closed down
too late. Have. Maximum impact as we are speaking,
there was a study from Columbia University
that came out today that said if we closed
down a week earlier, we would have saved more
than one third of the lives that have long
been lost so far.
And if we had closed down two weeks earlier,
we would have saved about 60 percent of the
lives that have been lost so far.
Similar things happened in 1918. Most cities
closed down too late to have maximum impact.
When we think about the communication that
we now see of federal and state guidelines
here, augmented by television, radio, internet,
social media, etc., how was it in 1918 through
1920 that most people were learning about
what was supposed to be done to stop the spread?
Well, of course, Brant was the only media
you didn't even have radio yet. You had rumor
and you print.
We were in a different situation than because
of the war. The government, the Wilson administration
focused everything on winning the war. They
passed a law which made it punishable by 20
years in prison, to quote. Auto right, print
or publish any disloyal, profane, scurrilous
or abusive language about the form of government
in the United States. So you could curse.
Some action the government took and you just
broke the law. Truth was not a defense. This
law was prosecuted vigorously. Congressman
Woods. Sentenced to more than 10 years in
prison for this law. It's also one that a
couple of memorable phrases came out of the
Supreme Court decision, which actually upheld
it.
Oliver Wendell Holmes, who is generally considered
a a singing, you know, a real upholder or
freedom of speech, actually wrote the opinion
upholding this law. And he used that phrase
clear and present danger in his opinion, along
with the analogy. You can't shout fire in
a crowded theater to justify upholding this
law. Anyway, that was important because also
the government had created a propaganda arm
and the architect of that. What was called
the Committee for Public Information wrote
that nothing and experience teaches us that
truth is superior to falsehood. The value
of an idea lies in its inspirational value.
It matters very little if it is true or false.
So on the one hand, the government was. Lying
to people in order to keep morale up for the
war. On the other hand, they were threatening
people with 20 years in the can.
For telling the truth if the truth seems critical
of the government, so influenza fell into
that infrastructure.
National public health leaders associated
with the government said things like this
is ordinary influenza by another name or you
have nothing to fear. If proper precautions
are taken, neither of those statements were
true, but they were echoed. In most places
around the country, many, you know, not just
echoed but quoted verbatim in most cities.
So initially people were led to believe this
was ordinary influenza by another name, but
it didn't take long. We're talking about almost
a matter of days before they realized. This
was something very different.
I wish we had more time to dig into it further.
But I do want to make sure people know the
book is The Great Influenza. The Story of
the Deadliest Pandemic in History.
And we've been speaking with the book's author,
John Barry from Tulane University. John, I
so appreciate your time. You're very welcome.